ria is a phenomenal baker who runs a
bakery in new york
on seeing the great success of her
business
she thought of growing it even bigger
and launching a new franchise of her
bakery in la
so for the funds she applied for a loan
of fifty thousand dollars from the
central bank
after completing her documentation for
the loan she comes to know that the bank
is rejecting her loan application due to
her loan borrowing limit of the amount
decided by the central financial system
furious with this situation she talked
to a friend lisa a finance expert to
understand how this whole centralized
financial system of banks works
and why did her loan get rejected lisa
explained to her that in centralized
finance banks and businesses use the
money that you invest or lend to make
profits and their overriding objective
is to make money
third parties or merchants like debit
credit card providers control money
transfers between the two end parties in
the financial system
each charging a fee for their services
and that is why her loan got rejected
because the loan amount exceeded the
limit decided by the bank or third
parties for her
ria was upset with the thought of not
being able to grow her business
and that is when lisa suggested ria to
opt for decentralized finance or defy
ria got a little confused by the term
and asked what is decentralized finance
lisa answered the decentralized finance
is a piece of code that eliminates
middlemen or banks by allowing
individuals business merchants and
corporations to perform financial
transactions using developing
technologies
peer-to-peer financial networks that
provide security protocols and
connectivity to the transactions are
used to accomplish this
stablecoin is a cryptocurrency backed by
an asset or tied to a fiat currency like
the dollar is at the concept's core ria
was fascinated and asked how it works
and how exactly defy could help her get
her loan approved
lisa further added that defy uses the
consensus mechanism to eliminate
centralized finance models by allowing
anyone or everyone to utilize financial
services
regardless of who they are or where they
are
the consensus mechanism refers to the
methods used to achieve agreement trust
and security across a decentralized
computer network
now this defy mechanism runs in a
decentralized environment
and this is where blockchain comes into
the picture
it provides the environment where you
can simply create your decentralized
programs or d apps according to your
requirement
in the blockchain network transactions
are stored in blocks and other users in
that network can verify them
if a transaction is verified by all its
verifiers the block is closed and
encrypted and a new block is created
containing information from the previous
block thus creating a chain of blocks
and these transactions are handled by
decentralized applications or say d-apps
lisa further explained that ria's loan
got rejected due to the lower limit by
the centralized financial system
but in d5 she can submit her loan
requirements into a decentralized
finance application dapp
and an algorithm would match her up with
peers who could help her
after that she'll have to agree to the
lender's terms to get her loan
the transaction is then recorded in the
blockchain where it will be securely
stored in a ledger that will make it
impossible to hack or any kind of
malicious intervention
and after that she'll receive her
required amount of money once it is
verified by the consensus mechanism
the lender can also then begin
collecting their payments at the
agreed-upon intervals from her
when she makes the payment using her d
app it goes through the same blockchain
process and the money is transferred to
the lender
ria was impressed and relieved that she
now could grow her business in a much
more secure and cheaper way all thanks
to defy
defy is meant to conduct transactions
using cryptocurrency
because technology is still evolving
it's difficult to say how if at all
existing cryptocurrencies will be
applied
so here's a question for you
which concept does defy use for its
implementation
a smart contracts b consensus algorithm
c
d apps
d
none of the above
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
decentralized finance is still in its
early stages of development
yet it is rapidly changing and expanding
to replicate the traditional financial
services ecosystem whether through
decentralized exchanges lending and
borrowing of various asset types or
insurance products
and it could have an impact on the
future of centralized financial
companies with defy being considered as
a cheaper faster and more relevant
alternative we hope you enjoyed this
video if you did a thumbs up would be
really appreciated here's your reminder
to subscribe to our channel and click on
the bell icon for more on the latest
technologies and trends thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simplylearn
[Music]
you